So I had a company that made
basically custom audio D.S.P. for
musical applications and I sold that and
I was kind of semi retired and
I was messing around with iOS apps
that were again audio oriented.
And I met Oliver who's the V.P. end here
and he was working on apps as well and
he came out here to Silicon Valley and
started a company called Origami.
And I've been kind of out of the game
for a while and was interested and so he
hired me into that startup and I moved
my family out here to Silicon Valley and
then that startup got acquired by Nest
and then this got acquired by Google and
I left Google about a year ago
to come here to Utah City and
head up the engineering team.